welcome back to new rock stars I'm
Jessica Clemens and this is a breakdown
of the third episode of Marvel's newest
Disney Plus show Echo we last left off
with Maya starting a new war of her own
showing everyone in New York the new
boss in town while still ignoring her
family and their wishes in this episode
we're introducing the black knife cartel
which might lead to their favorite enemy
Bullseye who last we saw was getting a
bionic freaking spine in the final
season of Daredevil we are slowly
threading in the Netflix Daredevil and
sneakily dropping little hints there's
so much to talk about so let's just jump
right into it but actually first before
we jump right into it don't forget to
check out nerd r. shop where right now
you can find merch inspired by the echo
series including a shirt featuring the
big man himself and a shirt with Echo
spelled out in ASL with bloody knuckles
grabbing a piece of merch From Nerd rot.
shop is a great way to support the
channel now let's get into it we open
this episode the same way we opened
episode one the same blue spiral
underneath Earth Scully tells Maya how
their grandmother Chola could trace
their roots to chaffa after the
previously on we jump to an old timey
title card first is the Marvel Studios
logo which flickers like an old school
film then it rolls to the Marvel
Spotlight logo and the spotlight font
really works for this they're setting up
an old school movie Western vibe to
frame the late 1800s especially since
this episode is centered around the LI
Horsemen and their steeds and heroic
Feats the next card gives us a border
now with the sun centered at the top it
says in the late 1800s Indian country
was infested with dangerous criminals
threatening the safety of the native
nations tribes establish their own
police force to bring these criminals to
Justice these Tribal Police were called
the LI Horsemen then the Sun at the top
turns into the chucktown national seal
the light Horsemen are actually a real
thing the principal Chief had six later
nine whom he appointed and who served as
his special agents in carrying messages
making arrests monitoring and banning
whiskey and assisting their government
enforcing the laws they had Americans
like coming in and people messing stuff
up so they had to have their own people
outside of the law that could govern it
they're basically like their own police
force they're also called light Horsemen
because they had to travel so light so
they're always ready to go and could
travel long distances chaka Cherokee
Chickasaw simol and Creek all had light
Horsemen these ones we're seeing right
now are technically called the asaba
amili tashka meaning Warrior who rides a
horse specifically the Chua horse you
just know the Foley artist had so much
fun recreating this scene you can hear
the horse clops but they're in the
grass it just sounds like a fake horse
hoof on cement and I love it it is so
easy to fall into a rut with food but
it's also so boring my problem is that
if it's left up to me I'll eat the same
boring stuff every single day like Zack
Huddleston which is exactly why I'm
thrilled when instead of having to
figure it out on my own cook Unity can
do it for me cook Unity is the first
chef to Consumer platform that delivers
freshly prepared pre-selected meals
right to your door weekly cook Unity is
basically a pipeline from your home to
dozens of talented chefs that cook
delicious inventive meals fresh everyday
in Regional micro kitchens not Warehouse
production facilities and the meals they
make are updated weekly so you can't get
bored you can pick from whopping 350
plus meals each week based on your
dietary needs including vegetarian
pescatarian and KY you know that's me
what kind of Cuisine do you like or just
I don't know give me chicken I won't
forget which could be the Esther Choice
Teriyaki roasted salmon or if you're
more in the mood for beef you could have
a Stacy bearing grilled Asian hanger
steak with charred broccolini variety is
the spice of life and with cook Unity
you can live a spicy life cook unity's
roster of Allstar chefs include Food
Network alums James Beard award winners
and acclaimed restauranteurs balancing
flavor and nutrition in the Creations
there is seemingly endless variety of
meals to choose from the subscription is
super flexible you can pause skip weeks
or cancel at any time and it's super
easy to do go to cook unity.com enrock
stars50 or click the link in the
description and use my code nrock
stars50 to get 50% off your first order
of cook Unity meals to try them out for
yourself as they ride through the
forested terrain we see a small area of
homes initially following the trail of
tear most of the people quickly Built
Homes that were constructed like log
cabins and over the next few years the
logs would shrink or create gaps so they
didn't last long but you'd see them sort
of lean over time and that's why the
houses in the background sort of look
like that and then another title card
then what I think is a squash being
merked and uprises a small woman this is
to clo played by Danny mallum one of
ekko's ancestors we've seen with the
wide brimmed hat and just like look here
the light Horsemen were traveling across
the entire chai Nation at the time and
this is the 1800s so it was different
clothing for all different weathers
heavy coats hats what have you they just
had all the gear prepared the title card
says her father was a light Horseman but
tuo was a might force all on her own at
the top of the frame is the sap sucker
that we keep seeing we see it again
later on another title card and this
must be a message from our ancestors or
possibly a warning but I think it's the
beginning of something new to come and
they're preparing her then her dad hands
her a rabbit stick a weapon for early
chak to Hunters card from Hickory limb
it is commonly used to kill rabbits or
small animals with the next title card
we see her mission is just to be a light
Horseman just like her father it's like
Maya following in her Father's Footsteps
though this one isn't working for fist
he tells her no women are life-givers
men are life takers the system was made
up of a matriarchal society like the
foundation of that Society is the women
they can birth and create new life
literally physically create new life but
also with Agriculture and then the men
just kill to protect eat and you know
some say to survive too says it best
though to give life means nothing if I
cannot protect it she storms off on
Horseback to a creek this Creek does
resemble the Creek West of the N cave in
Mississippi it's surrounded by woods and
since it's part of the Chaka creation
story would make sense for how the
ancestors are reaching TLO through their
Waters she braids her hair knowing it's
for Chaka Warriors for Chaka men and
they will see her for who she is it was
common in Chaka traditional hair men
wear their hair long enough to make two
braids and I also love that we often see
Maya with two braids or at least one
hopefully that means she's a warrior the
light Horsemen are in action until it's
a trap a shootout commences when the
title card says meanwhile T clo senses
something the frame no longer gives the
chak doo or the Sun but the sapsucker
again back at the creek TLO senses
something then she sees the spiral
symbol and like Eko we see in the sky
her eyes in a sequence we see chaa then
loak from the last episode she
disappears in the blink of an eye like
we saw Maya's mom do in the kitchen then
we cut the chaa staring at her hands
puzzled L we see the first of the chock
toop people under the Earth then back to
loak playing stickball from the last
episode the spiral beams brighter and
then tuo lifts her head concerned we're
back at the shootout and here comes tuo
hitting every single Mark her father
releases a war cry impressed and proud
by the looks of it so we now know
through toow my will harness Supreme
accuracy then we cut to the intro that's
my new found addiction Chola is pissed
and buzzing at the Gate of the security
cam you can see the Oklahoma The Daily
Newspaper in Oklahoma she yells yokei
when buzzed in which means thank you
she's fed up when she enters scully's
pawn shop and Grandpa over here is just
trying to get laid and I really I love
Scully I think he's one of my favorite
characters now his shirt says the
natives app play off the Beatles and
their ABY Road album cover Jokes Aside
they're not together anymore and that
actually makes me sad and I wonder if
it's because of Maya's mother's passing
that they just split up at the end
skolly responds to her saying halito
which means hello and Chaka we see a
sign when Chola is seated that says
payday loans we buy gift cards check
cashing so truly scolly does all he's a
jack of all trades also I'm sorry but
Chola is me when he sits next to and she
tells him to go sit over there I think I
do that to literally anybody that gets
too close to me I also love that biscuit
damn near total her truck and is only
getting $100 back from the pawn shop
like that will do anything also that hat
behind Scully says young at heart
slightly older in other places and
what's not to love about him and okay
I'll stop pointing out the ridiculous
things fine I just love this little pawn
shop then we C to Vicky snitching out
Maya's location like we all knew would
happen and he's on the phone with the
crazy bald guy from the last episode his
name is zaye played by Andrew Howard who
played Luther Banks and Agents of Shield
we thought this could be Theodor zaro
from the comics who ran the black knife
cartel and was up against Bullseye and I
still believe it's him the rumor online
is that his name is Theo Zayn and he
runs the cartel alongside someone else
also later you can see the double swords
tattooed on his goons in the comics they
had it tattooed on their foreheads so he
might be expecting an appearance from
our favorite madman and from our
favorite madman I mean bullseye look I
just want to see him in the suit he is a
crazy person I get it he's had a hard
life I'm not trying to excuse his
actions because he definitely drives in
a car with a woman that's dead in the
passenger seat I think about that like
once a day we get aaya down by a lake
when she turns she's faced with chaa who
shifts between herself and the people
they were before emerging when Maya
takes a deep breath visions of the sap
sucker leaving their hand and flying to
the post the night of Maya's mom dying
too and Maya's dead mother back to tuo
braiding her hair in the forest near the
creek running calmly tuo then removes
the belt from her father's hat a woman
squeezing droplets of water onto a
pregnant belly this is a woman we saw in
the snippet of what's to come in the
first episode we then get low beams of
light like you're in a stretch moving
through a hospital TLO screams something
urgent like a warning and then Maya's
drugged we start noting that when she's
clearly in danger or beside herself the
visions of her ancestors ease her or
just warn her so we saw Maya's oldest
ancestor the first to enter the passage
relay their message through the sap
sucker and it looks like they're all
entangled by the spiral link it was
revealed by can we get some toast that
and spoilers so can we get some toast
said that Maya's Powers will not be the
same as the ones in the comics still
she'll be empowered by her ancestors
when threatened and that so far is
looking to be true not only with Maya
but with tuo and Lok as well this
character did copy many other characters
in the comics and if you want to make a
story that gives her a different link
then I think this is a better one and I
like it it's giving me like a heartfelt
Shazam Maya awakens as the new disco
ball and Henry skating rink frees
herself by wiggling out of her
prosthetic then it's silent and inw
walks Vicky and two women Vicky and
Gracie both have the same little cat
tattoo and I could not confirm where it
comes from if you know let me know it's
kind of heinous they've already tied up
Henry and now they've tied Maya to an
exercise machine this game rink is just
wild it's like a half gym half skating
rink later we see he has like laser tag
it just got too much stuff bunny then
shows up at the skating rink little does
you know it's under siege she goes
around back and runs into Henry he signs
leave now go thankfully she picks up
what he's putting down then just when
you think Bonnie made it she gets yanked
up tied down and thrown in with Maya
who's been avoiding her this entire time
this moment is also just so
heartbreaking y'all are adults just
share your feelings and I know they
can't right now because they're
restraint but soon they can just sign to
each other how they love each other Maya
scoots her spring-loaded boot knife and
cuts herself free then frees Bonnie
clever girl Bonnie confronts Maya about
never returning her calls or emails for
years and Maya is unfazed Bonnie's
chewing her out and Maya's just sitting
there like an what do you want me to do
about
it I kind of like it about her when
Vicki and his goons walk into Maya and
Bonnie's holding area they walk over a
red circle with a black dot and a Target
and I'm sorry still if this isn't
foreshadowing for Bull's ey specifically
in the Colombian connection with Theodor
Zoro and the rest of the black knife
cartel from the comic book I don't know
what it is but I think he's coming
there's still a possibility that Henry
doesn't necessarily work for Fisk he
could be like 3 degrees off from Fisk so
what if his dealings were with the black
knife cartel at the beginning this would
make sense also to why Zay knew Henry
and approached him like their old
friends and I bet Henry is hiding the
black knife Cartel Tattoo under his
wristband I don't think it's off I think
that's something we should think about I
think he works for someone that's just
not necessarily Fisk once Bridget points
a gun at Bonnie The Sound and Music fade
we hear ekko's low heartbeat she's Cal
than usual probably because she's not
restrained and knows she can kick
everybody's asses then Maya punches the
hell out of Bonnie with absolutely no
warning zero warning her warning was the
Sucker Punch though they take Bonnie I'm
sure they also have a plan then Here
Comes Zayn he also didn't bring the
money because he had to assess the
situation first and didn't want to get
double crossed which makes sense and
Vicki's an idiot Maya begins macgyvering
a BB gun with a roller skate and some
bolts while bridg is watching a video
tutorial on holding a hostage it's
credited as militia mommy podcaster and
the name is credited as Shelby hall
right when the video says to protect
yourself Maya shoots out the lights with
a makeshift electric BB gun then this
dummy walks into the dim lit trap and
gets beat the hell out of and it feels
just like Netflix's Daredevil when he
turn off those lights and just beat
everyone's asses then exactly what
happens to Vicki happens so now there's
no Bounty and a dead Vicki then the
lights turn freaking red and again
doesn't this remind you of like every
Daredevil fight scene with the
contrasting lights and also yeah Rob
Zombies Dracula plays and of course it
does cuz why wouldn't it Henry leads the
go to the breaker that's at the laser
tag area of the skate ring and this man
literally gets blasted with electricity
and stops the music for a second Henry
laughs and abruptly gets punched in the
face and this is the second Sucker Punch
of the evening and I I love it and then
the music starts again honestly this was
a great sequence then Here Comes Maya
beating all that ass in the dark it's a
real don't get it twisted I'm not stuck
in here with you you're stuck in here
with me moment it's so good then we see
the scene we've got from the trailer of
Maya falling through the make America
skate again wall when she lands on the
man she Palms his head and smashes it
into the rink and blood splatters out
and this is just metal as hell she then
channels too and aims that gun at a goon
hitting his hand and picks up another
goons gun the Precision of TLO is out
when she kicks this man in the face his
blood splatters onto the disco ball she
hits the goons directly in the head
killing all of them then we start to
only hear her heartbeat again she's
still channeling TLO though the sound
comes back after flipping this man on
his ass she gets tossed into a pin ball
game machine called The Legend of the
coyote the choreography here is just
very fun it's very fun it's very good
and like like Daredevil it's like 6
minutes long she then kicks this man
standing on top of an air hockey table
what was he planning on doing pile
driving my second favorite Gruesome Kill
is Maya getting bullets through this guy
it's remarkable other than a movie quick
and the undead is also a board game
about Outlaws and you're the leader and
you need to control the West Fort by
killing the undead plague it's also a
game where Maya lasso whips the out
of everyone in sight channeling too
again like when using the rabbit stick
Maya starts tossing ski balls at
everyone and I'm also just still more
astonished there's so much to do at this
skating ring cuz mine sucked as a child
regardless they got Henry and Maya tie
kneeling again because they captured
Bonnie and Maya wasn't ready to risk
that then R is is about to kill Henry
Zayn's phone rings in its New York
Minute by The Eagles I love that Zayn
has chosen this song as Wilson fisk's
ringtone and the lyrics really match
What's Happening Here in a New York
minute everything can change and oh boy
do they when he answered the phone
flustered it was clear that the man he
was talking to had bigger plans and they
let Bonnie Henry and Maya Lee Zayn is a
little irritated with it and just like
in the comics he's sort of hotheaded and
crazy so nothing good will come of this
then the black knife cartel just leaves
like that Bonnie and Maya step outside
and Maya finally apologizes for punching
Bonnie Square in the face luckily Maya
promises no one will hurt Bonnie she
wouldn't let that happen though she did
just punch her in the face and I'm never
going to let her live that down then
Bonnie takes off believing Maya so now
we know Bonnie will eventually maybe get
kidnapped again or hurt and Maya will
have to step in the way this is why
Peter wears a mask so no one in his
family can get hurt even though they all
got hurt back at Henry's office he's
upset and shaken for some reason it's
clear to everyone but Maya that Kingpin
saved her however Henry still decides to
fight with her then when we remain by
Samantha crane plays and we get these
gorgeous overhead shots of Oklahoma my
little house resembles TLO small village
town being surrounded by trees and away
from everyone else Scully arrives with a
gift it's the prosthetic leg guard it's
gold with a classic traditional Chaka
design and a Sun at the top he says it's
for the Chaka Warrior then he lectures
May on see and her grandma and it just
looks like these two will never talk
unless one is dying or one's almost dead
they just refuse to talk to each other
Ekko goes out on her bike and we see
scenes of everyone down in the dumps
Bonnie at a bar Chola at church not even
singing biscuit is getting down in the
back singing then we see Wilson Fisk off
the IV drip and doing something nervous
and weird with his hands His Eye Is
Still bandaged and he's clearly blind in
it but he's shown his face finally we
assume he's called off the hit on Maya
but we don't actually know what we do
know is this is the beginning of his
wild ass coming in we still haven't seen
that moment in the trailer where he
agrees to go to war with Maya and that's
it for my breakdown of the third episode
of Ekko tune in tomorrow for episode
Four's breakdown and follow on Instagram
Twitter at Lulu Clemens follow new
Rockstar subscribe to new rockstars for
more analysis of everything you love
check out the break room where we'll be
covering Echo and all everything else
you want thanks for watching and I'll
see you
[Music]
later